[Music]
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt
you are not my first choice you were
here at the request of admiral kazansky
aka iceman he seems to think that you
have something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
with all due respect sir i'm not a
teacher
i just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
and we're off
here we
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you i'm not gonna
make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
those are your pilots
anything happens to them
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
yet
[Music]
three
after 34 years tom cruise returns his
maverick
this is a competition film about family
friendship and sacrifice
it's a love letter to aviation
we're going to show you what it's really
like to be a top gun
you just can't create this kind of
experience unless you shoot it live
in order for us to accomplish this we
have the greatest fighter pilots in the
world working with us
we're working with a brand new camera
system that allows us to put six imax
quality cameras inside the cockpit with
the actors verify cameras are on check
camera's on there you go
it's amazing what we see in the cockpit
what an audience is going to experience
thanks to tom all the actors becoming
accustomed to the g-forces by all the
training that they're doing
it is aggressive you can't act that the
distortion the face they're pulling
seven and a half eight g's that's
sixteen hundred pounds of force
i am so proud of them and what they've
done and it is heavy duty
putting us up in these jets it's very
serious that's why everybody thought it
would be impossible and i think when tom
hears that something's impossible or it
can't be done that's when he gets to
work
flying one of these fighter jets is an
absolute thrill ride we want to make
sure that the audience has the same
experience
aviation film like this has never been
done and chancellor will never be done
again
[Music]
you